hello welcome back to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hunger to be Tuesday
at two p.m. pacific right here on
gamespot com I'm your host Daniel to our
how you doing it's been a while that III
thing happened and we took a week off it
turns out not much happened in the world
of video games anyway unless you're a
destiny fat which is why we've got Eric
T and Alex new house to fans of destiny
Eric lovely see wearing a shirt today I
thinks you must have known you were
coming on and talk bad all the stuff to
tap in with destiny and there's been a
lot of stuff happening over the past
couple weeks there was that whole
collector's edition for raw there was
the the backlash to the eurogamer
interview at e3 and now as it turns out
if you're a fan of red bull they've got
something for you there as well and you
two guys have like different
perspectives on a lot of this stuff
first of all how much destiny have you
guys actually played Eric how many
characters do you have I have 334 I dick
just finished that so I have a lot of
hours I don't wanna talk about it I'm
like wow you don't want to know you
never look at how many accidentally
poured / played yeah you don't do that
figured out what about you I have won 34
and 131 okay not as much as him still
over 120 hours playing destiny photo
from that I can calculate you probably
done all right it's been a while fair
enough and so you're obviously big fans
of the game both of you at differing
opinions on let's say the collectors
edition thing first of all so Alex
what's your take on what they don't
suffer for those who don't know what
what happened with this what I will talk
about the pricing and and have it
eventually ended up coming out so when
bungie the developer of Destiny
announced their new expansion for the
game they said that you know they're
going to sell this expansion in two
different forms first you can buy it
standalone or you can buy it in like a
pack that comes with the game the first
two expansions and the new expansion
it's kind of and par for the course yeah
and so one of the so you could also get
the collector's edition which is the
that bundle with some extra stuff and
that that extra stuff is the problem
here that extra stuff was originally
exclusive to the collectors edition you
have to pay 80 bucks to get you know
both the the base game and the three
expansions and then also to get those
in-game items and so players who already
have had you know I've already been
playing destiny like Eric and I we were
pretty frustrated about that we wanted
those in-game items we thought that
we should be able to get those without
having to pay 80 bucks for the the base
game you are young yeah and four and two
expansion packs presumably had already
bought yeah and then they're taking in
King which I guess you guys will be
purchasing and so the backlash was that
you were essentially having to dump 80
bucks to get that sort of that little
piece of content as well obviously as
the taking and everything else so this
way bungee clearly are trying to like
get people up to speed like new car new
players into the game so the eventual I
guess end to this story or as we have it
now is that you can i just buy that for
20k around yeah so you can buy the new
expansion for 40 bucks and then you can
also pay an additional twenty dollars to
get that like a pack of all that content
which is three emotes three class items
and three shaders alright so Tay what
what are those pieces of content are
they like gameplay changing are they are
they chase their vanity purely vanity I
would say maybe you can argue that the
class armors the way they work now is
they give you slight bonuses to leveling
up your gun faster but that kind of
stuff doesn't influence or affect the
gameplay and that's the biggest thing
for me like because like people will say
oh it's like a micro transaction almost
yeah kind of like but you spending the
extra 20 bucks it's like maybe you think
you look cooler but at the end of the
day it's like that's about it like
they're not you're not gaining any type
of like power or like some type of lead
ahead of some weapons you're not doing
anything too crazy I think the
collectors like the hard copy one does
have some guns in it but it's not going
to be better like that much better than
anything else that they're all pretty
like similar so so you're kind of okay
of it you're like holy okay that's it
youryour it's not like Stockholm
Syndrome where you got that it's why
it's it's it's just vanity stuff it sits
on the face of its it's like getting
skins for my character exact odor so
yeah I think illegal edges I I
definitely had more of a problem when it
was eighty dollars yeah like for
everything because then it kind of like
I get why everyone's mad it's like oh so
I guess everything we bought before was
like twenty bucks yeah worth you know in
theory but not like the moment it
happened I told Alex was like oh we're
getting at fifty percent off now its
twenty bucks i'll totally i'll totally
buy it like but but that's me like i'm
willing to spend the twenty bucks for
those shaders and stuff like that not
everybody's like that but again it
doesn't affect the game so whatever so
Alex you obviously don't agree with yes
I actually look at this differently
way I look at it does you know the pact
that they were selling for 80 bucks with
the base game in the three expansions
and all these items you can break it up
now basically into okay the the taken
King expansion is being sold for forty
dollars okay the base game and the first
two expansions are now being sold for
twenty because you have that extra pack
also for twenty would you go buy yeah so
you know what what Eric just hinted at
is like now I feel like my previous
purchases that I've already spent a
hundred bucks on is now just valued at
twenty dollars and this you know I
understand you know having been a day
one player that games are going to
depreciate in value but Destiny's a
unique situation and that is still very
active game and yeah you know still has
a huge player bases aren't obviously
still supporting it's less than a year
old yeah exactly so I you know as a
player who's put over a hundred twenty
hours in this game I want to feel like
my value is being recognized by Bungie I
want to feel like you know bungee is
recognizing me as a person who's
dedicated my time to this and then
saying that they expect us to still pay
twenty bucks for this end game content
and then that they're acquitting that
content value eyes with the original
based game and the first two expansions
seems a bit ridiculous to me so it's
just a problem for you guys going
forward as players because presumably
you know they said this is their
ten-year game they're going to keep
doing this early signal destiny to will
eventually come out and they'll they'll
do the same thing for you guys like
obviously a lot of people you know sit
six months off of the new release
schedule so they can save a bunch of
cash on games instead of a good time is
that possible if your destiny pair can
you just not buy into this stuff day one
and still have a good time or are you
kind of locked into their content
release because the problem definitely
had at the start was that there wasn't
really that much stuff to do which is
like people are so thirsty for these
expansion packs so like Eric do you
think like you have an option not to buy
this stuff for is that really if you're
a real destiny player you sort of locked
in you like have to do it kind of like
Waterwalker yeah I think if you're
playing destiny and you're consistently
playing destiny is hard to not buy the
new content because like you said we're
start like we're kind of starving for
the content because like even with house
of wolves as we had discussed before I'm
like yeah it's probably gonna last good
four ish weeks maybe six weeks and it's
kind of done that like I've dropped off
again i still play once or twice a week
because of my friends i might play a
little bit more just but less right yeah
and so basically it's just like well
when's the next one coming out now
everyone's juiced because in two months
I'll get to play taking king and that
should supposedly be a little bit bigger
than just your normal DLC expansion pack
but who knows how much bigger but
they're making it seem at least like
within on like you know somewhere in
that territory have one to two or maybe
24 lucky but yeah we have like you just
kind of have to buy into it if you want
it but if you're more casual Bungie has
done a good job in the sense that they
do let players that don't buy into it
still kind of participate in small ways
kind of like to get you to want to buy
it right like they leave all these
little red combs up like oh here why
don't you participate in these like
little events and then kind of hope that
that sparks you into buying the next
piece of content does it split the user
base though do you think like that there
are there's content that obviously like
high level players who are playing with
their buddies will want to play and then
you're like if Alex it's like you know
whoever you ride with like to your
friends whatever decided like they were
going to get the pot you'd feel
compelled to get it as well right
because yeah play with them anymore yeah
definitely and I think Eric's totally
right you do feel compelled if you're a
consistent player of Destiny to buy the
content and I actually think that
results in a less split player base than
other games that have you know DLC drops
because it is such in a lot of ways it
is such an essential part of the Destiny
experience to have that extra content
and you know this is another reason why
I don't really like what they're doing
with the twenty-dollar pack of endgame
content is you know because there they
are in a sense bundling all of that
original content together in a 60 door
for a 60-vote secure our price which to
me seems like the better like that is
clearly the better deal here like you're
getting like one of the big criticisms
of Destiny was that it was kind of you
know light on launch and people are
start for continent and so by bundling
all that together you actually have an
experience that is worth it but then you
know bungee is still saying to players
who have been paying for it along the
way that hey we know that you love
destiny so we're going to give you this
option that we know you're going to buy
because you want that content anyways
and so you're going to pay that twenty
dollars for that so it's going to
continue to be a problem because like
okay both of you clearly love it like
you've paid about 130 hours and change
God knows I can probably like 300 hours
or something like that getting right now
sir clearly like if we're going to talk
about this as a value proposition
you guys probably feel like you've
gotten value out of it but if we like
break it down so what destiny original
game I'm really sixty dollars the first
expansion pack 20 they're both 20 unless
you bought the season pass which then
made it 35 35 okay so let's for the sake
of argument will say a hundred bucks for
the two of them right then the taken
king is another forty forty bucks so
that means in the first year gonna spend
the one hundred and forty dollars I'm
like Activision cooking learnt this from
World of Warcraft and what lizard is one
that they merged and they ended up like
being involved as business partners but
like burning crusade was forty bucks he
came at I think two years after the
release of i was at 06 and man like
whole new area like flying man's the
battleground stuff they added two new
races like do you guys feel like you're
being nickeled and dimed on this list so
the difference is like you bring up a
good point like you look at the overall
cost of like destiny for the whole year
assuming you by taking king but i look
at it too is like okay if you bought
while and you play for a year guess what
you're still spending over one hundred
forty dollars because it remember it's a
subscription game mmm so it's sixty
dollars and fifteen dollars a month so
at the end of the day if you're one year
wow is still more expensive than my one
year destiny yeah and i granted yes
you're right though in terms of like the
like the world like world of warcraft is
bigger but it's set because it's an
MMORPG anyone who thinks destiny is an
MMORPG is crazy it has elements of that
but like for me like you said value wise
like I've gotten my bang for my buck out
of it and like again I just want to
reiterate that the twenty dollars nobody
has to spend that twenty dollars on it
it's just there for them but yeah I mean
this is also where I differ from
American that I'm coming from at this
from like I'm more of like a first
person shooter perspective where I'm
used to getting a sixty-dollar
experience that is you know cohesive
that is there's a lot of bang for your
buck in that package and so coming to
this where it's more like a platform or
the building upon it every couple months
and you're expected to pay for that more
like an MMO I'm very unused to that and
I'm very very much feel like I'm being
nickeled and dimed alone at the time and
the nature of Destiny's is that because
you start for content you're always
looking for more content even if that
content comes in the form of emails to
shaders right okay also different to
though like because like yes you come
from a like a halo background or
whatever like their DLC is like oh
here's new multi
Claire maps where's with destiny it's
like here's new multiplayer but here's
new single-player contact in Halo you
never felt like like destiny like
[ __ ] nothing going down half the time
like it's great that you're playing with
all your buddies but you are replaying
the same stuff from like I'm not here so
I can really speak to but just like
listening to you guys talking about it
seems like there's a lot of repetition
whereas when you're playing a hail of
like three a year later there's so much
[ __ ] in that game we're so much to do
that you kind of didn't really feel
repetitive at anything exactly and
that's why you see people you know at e3
for example going crazy for the armor
shooter they were getting out there is
because anything that's new in that game
is so coveted that it drives people to
pay money for things that otherwise and
other games i probably wouldn't and
that's the biggest problem i have with
this eric to change in the tide of games
it's just a gimmick I prefer work yeah
better for worse like I understand it I
get it I can also understand why people
are upset about it and like there's
frustrations with it obviously but
that's just kind of the trend of where
games are going right now it's all like
can we make a good decent solid
foundation of a game and then how do we
get more money out of people and like
sadly that's just where it is it's just
are you gonna spend the money or not
like you don't have to you know at the
end of the day if you enjoy playing it
and you get your value out of it like I
do then it's great right but it's not
for everybody like I get it I totally
understand it's a divisive issue I think
this is their 10-year plan then we're
probably going to be talking about this
for quite a while and the next come in
the coming years and let us know what
you think of course in the comments
below do you play destiny have you spent
140 or a hundred dollars and willing to
spend on our 40 bucks or do you feel
like it being nickeled and dimed by
Activision as well I let us know below
and we got loads more coming up today
I'm love we're gonna talk about fallout
4 and a little bit and we're going to
talk about a batman arkham knight we
actually haven't had a chance to talk to
Kevin since his review end up pissed off
some people that's what I got them on to
talk about that but first off we have a
new immense and trailer games still
coming out this is the villain check it
out
some are so cool
what a wonderful III it was and one of
my favorite announcements and many of
yours was finally seeing some hot
fallout 4 nonsense it looks pretty great
it's coming out this year and it's got a
bunch of new features that we've been
asking for in the series for a long time
Justin hey Walt anja baman are here both
fans of the series and we're going to
talk about some other stuff that we'd
like to see in the game and coming up
later this year first of all though they
added a bunch of stuff that we already
got like they have a bunch of stuff that
we already wanted like better shooting
and stuff Justin what what did you think
about what they shou shou to fallout 4 I
its loop it's everything you want I mean
it's one of those just big world gates
the reveal of it is itself just so
exciting uh even though we knew it was
going to be in Boston like the the fact
that it opens up the those more
possibilities for like what are these
people gonna be like what's this world
gonna be them because even though it's
still in America it still this
post-apocalyptic wasteland and like it's
gonna be new characters it's going to be
like a whole new setting a whole new
basically a world to explore and that's
one of the things that I think I'd
really like to see more of an fallout 4
is like we know that they're all these
different vaults that they well they
have all these different experiments and
one thing that I think was obsidian with
oblivion that they did really well is
every new Vegas you know so well with
the the Oblivion series is like I was
talking to you about this earlier is
that you have all this Lauren things
you're able to explore and one of them
are the books like I love getting books
and reading through in and like being
immersed in this world but I don't like
actually doing it on my TV screen so
like I I downloaded this kindle version
of all of the books in the game that's
so good and I'd love to be able to do
something like that and fallout like
because there is so now like it's an
even more expanding universe there's so
much more going on in the world like I
love exploring that outside of the game
and when getting that sent to me either
my Kindle or my phone yeah I like that
because it's like the test I put so much
time into crafting these worlds and
having all this text and it kind of
doesn't really feel like the right time
to read it like even I think the witcher
at the moment I've had a bunch over the
weekend and like taking time to even
read one of those books as somebody who
read some of the books it's like a
really nice little past time and it
doesn't feel like the right place to do
it so yeah you wanted to be a part of
the game as well one problem I think
destiny has is that almost all
that story is buried outside of the game
like you have to go outside to even have
a modicum of understanding what's going
on where is the fallout games of the
Oblivion games there was those always
been contained you know what's going on
but they add color they had a richness
to the world that makes it even more fun
to explore Andy one of the things that
obviously Justin touched upon obsidian
there and you're a big fan of a new
Vegas yeah one of the things you were
talking about before we went on was the
the faction element of that which I'd
actually completely forgotten about that
stuff wasn't in for like three and in
New Vegas up sitting sort of played
around with that and had you picking
which faction for that crazy fight at
the end I actually only completed New
Vegas about two weeks ago finally I like
loaded up my save game [ __ ] up the
Great Khans pretty bad and you'd like to
see that come on into fallout 4 yeah
because the Carver systems always been
in file gives been hugely like you know
things since the beginning but the
faction reputations came in and follow
two and then they were kind of gone in
fallout 3 they're back in New Vegas and
you're like yeah it gives you the
opportunity to do quests for those
factions go through those storylines get
deeper into the backstory of you know
characters and elements there which you
know but this is really strong at doing
that because they do it in Skyrim they
do it in their oblivion games where you
do the black hand missions and their
freakish deep as hell and they're
awesome that's like its own game you do
the Thieves Guild miss you want to do
all the guild missions and stuff because
they're just so rich and you get like
rewarded you get reputation you get new
abilities and armor sets yeah cuz then
this is all this is all like kind of
missing in fallout 3 in a way it was you
had your main quest Nia had like the
side quests were actually rather small
but there yet I feel like the only like
large ones were like the Brotherhood of
Steel right and that was like a good
faction one but it also had like endgame
it had like game overall yeah tie in so
that you had to do it but yeah in New
Vegas certainly you could do like all
the little factions and depending on how
far you've gotten what you did like
really affected the outcome of the
entire game but you also got to know
those storylines really well so that
that's something I think they're missing
I mean besides all the other stuff they
added any three were like you know
you've got the second screen experience
with good boy and come on guys freaking
crafting system destroy right now like
yeah all this [ __ ] is is already like we
didn't ask for this but it's yes I
really hot stuff was like murmured
be like yeah increased crafting with
something a lot of people talked about I
feel like that and actual good first
person shooting right and like you're a
massive new vegas yes but yeah it was
always a problem it was always a problem
and New Vegas did add aim down sights
which make like cool till I use some of
the guns that you could it kind of also
like highlighted how shitty those guns
golly highlight how shitty was and you
get the cinematic like kill cam and
stuff which was cool so I hope they
bring all that over honestly like I the
list of stuff I came up with the stuff
they added four new vegas that I hope
they carry over like the hardcore mode
yes where you have to sleep eat limb you
have to get your limbs repaired by
doctors yeah partially heal them like
it's not that hard it's not that hard I
ended up not being that bad in the grand
scheme like you just sleep and eat and
it's all it's all good but it's but it's
kind of fun some stuff I think they
should add in the cooking stuff haven't
was in New Vegas new dog though yeah
they got all those so here's some things
go for it from the other games I think
they should bring back that I think a
lot of people will hate okay so the
first game had a hardcore time pressure
from the very first quest you had to
find the water ship ultra vault was
gonna die which is pretty awesome
actually because like you had to like
get on you had to roleplay it freakin do
it you had like a fire under your ass
ago this [ __ ] done yeah do you ever feel
that way in The Witcher where you're
kind of like yeah we're doing this I
should probably be helping me very
meditating like to get I'm merchant to
like replenisher gold stash and we're
like what if series like dying out there
and likes because you're always looking
begging but i think is a behind her but
then you're like i just spent like five
days on his werewolf quest i just like
meditated for years that good like some
ice or river when I started out the
witcher likely when you get past that
first area i was like yeah you know i
have stuff going on but i guess i'm just
gonna get in a boat and sail all over
that sexy what's going on so like so but
the great part about fall it was you it
was like act one was time pressure yeah
but then act 2 opened up and you could
actually do it it was pretty short in
the first version of the game you could
actually lose the game again by failing
the time the clock but in version like
1.1 they update it to be like 13 game
years before you actually don't worry
they had something cool like that where
i thought four was like I don't know 50
game years and then you're [ __ ] like
that would be amazed
one thing in Fallout to drug addiction
really uh well you couldn't you can get
addicted good productive in 3 i'm not
sure if you got addicted or if it was
just drinking too fast i use it i wanna
bring back like jet usage because like
if you're in a fight in the early game
you had to like boost and you're like
all i have is jet oh god like there we
go and then you're like an addict and
you have to go through all this to get
to get out of it um yeah oh one thing
that but does this great at that I hope
and we kind of don't know cool actors
playing a big role Oh meme Neeson Liam
Neeson's as the freaking dad in fallout
3 nether I Matthew Perry was in Vegas
yeah he was gonna use a massive Colette
fan as well that's why you're involved
in the project I wonder now because they
financed the voice actors I wonder had a
no [ __ ] I think so yeah I saw some
people on Twitter said that that's who
they were there kind of relatively
unknown actors in the in the area so you
never know maybe they've got a bigger
voice talent crew what you're gonna who
got it we need like a secret one like a
big kenny i was guarding Freeman yeah
did Skyrim have like a like a notable I
don't know if it is you know dragon was
played by [ __ ] Patrick Stewart
projects to know that was oblivion
pursuing it oh you're right oh god I
totally forgot about that so that's what
I'm talking about hey that's all you
have to say about fall for i kind of
think like just it's from playing The
Witcher i think is where I've like
pulled along by like inspiration like I
really I'd love a horse like we oh dude
you've already seen I feel like horses
and open world games is almost like a
one and done like it kind of works we've
seen the like this massive airship we've
seen the vertibird zarnow pilot able and
or at least you can imagine them they
will drive you around yeah we don't know
if you're able to drive yourself so I'd
like imagine if you could finally get
cars working and there's like the super
weapon that maybe you aim it stuff maybe
or that's part of quest who knows maybe
that's just Megaton yeah visited who
know but the other thing I kind of
wouldn't mind from fallout is a you I
guess this is probably just a byproduct
of the fact that New Vegas is now back
in 2009 I think it came out and how does
that the quests in not gain Justin were
there was the main quest and then there
was like the side quest were kind of
these relatively small diversions like
you talked about going into the crazy
little faults and like it meeting
somebody and meeting up didn't we go on
the thing in which are is that I've done
side quests which
ended in five minutes and I've done sigh
quite sure which have gone on for like
three hours that's sort of variety
that'll be like where you don't really
know what's the main quest anymore I
think would be really fun so and that's
something that fits i think that fallout
feeling more as well that you are just
kind of exploring this waistline like
there shouldn't be a narrative like
everyone's experience should be
different no matter when you started
when you when you finish playing and
like maybe you'll just feel like oh I
came to to for me that was a good ending
point like maybe I won't necessarily
find and solve every quest and get every
puzzle yeah I was just exploring this
world and that's what I got out of it
they've already added one thing that I
would have always wanted which is an
amazing dog well not out some games they
should have all those out in three just
wasn't Donna me yeah yeah he could also
die apparently this one can't die Oh
invincible dogs yeah because we don't
want dead dogs yeah dude the only reason
to get the dog in these games is to just
put your fat boy and like all of your
heavy weapon [ __ ] do you only ever use
when some badness comes down and just
give it to Fox hey boy and then whatever
dog just call them over and baby like
yeah okay hey boy let's trade yeah trade
was one about you yeah last thing to add
habita you can play once the game is
finished because they [ __ ] this twice
they had it in fallout 3 which they
patched it out yeah eventually but new
vegas was the same thing I complete a
new vegas and it tells you the story of
the waistline then they're like and then
you're done here's the credits Todd
Howard and I'm hey all I mean the big
criticism of thought three was the main
line questions kind of man yeah and then
like everything else was amazing so yeah
if they can figure they can pull from
The Witcher and just say like look
here's how you do freakin quests sure
like request structure 2015 Oh what if
they pulled from the witch or something
like and went like that you have a
different universe alright gonna be a
collectible card game it's also going to
be a part of its own app just separately
like they follow shelter if you tell me
that Gwen's is actually exactly the same
of what for and all my stuff will carry
over I'm definitely in and one last
thing to talk about in relation to fall
out I've spent most of the past week
sitting on the toilet playing fallout
shelter are you guys still playing now I
picked it up at like right when it came
out III to like capture some gameplay
and
half distracted I think this is the
shitty gameplay I captured I'd like to
too many things happening I was like I
don't I can't deal with this game right
now all the way is so [ __ ] cartoony
this isn't all out come on I looks great
like that that art style the way the it
ships when you move it is like giving
that fake 3d look yeah but I feel like
the more I play it doesn't really change
like I'm still just kind of doing the
same thing over and over it's just
management time management at that point
but uh this is kind of like real life
boring i do management things already
I've got a 45 people in line at the
moment I had a real bad time there for a
while when nothing was working and I had
to like spend a good like two hours just
stopping everyone from being infected
with radiation because the water wasn't
working but now it's like growing up and
there's this thing we can send them out
to the wasteland yes and this sounds
cool i didn't get to this it's cool but
if you don't recall them they're like I
send them out like loads of stimpacks
and they basically pick up a shitload of
guns and like and that's how you get all
your equipment guns and outfits for your
character and outfits are the best
because they give you perks I didn't
realize for the longest time that they
gave you park so I was just like holding
on third and doing nothing and but my
guys always die so I end up just piss
pick sending a match paying their like
revived fee and then getting them to
come back again just like waiting to see
how much they get before they die and
then pulling them back in but all this
stuff all like the training centers it
kind of takes a long time to like pop
people into these rooms and going to
make them go and charm and look and all
that sort of stuff but you're right it
kind of feels like it doesn't really
have an end so what an end it would be
if this [ __ ] pulled into fallout 4 is
the end yeah did you imagine that what
if you tried that right like doing side
games on the Xbox Live where's like oh
but all your money carries over to fable
whatever yeah I know oh yeah or what if
this like what if this made an outpost
like you could find whatever one you
made all four twenties out there I think
vol 4 20 probably already exists I have
I have a family in there called in
Newtons and I've named every one of
their child's fig so I love the idea
that like I'll just turn like they don't
even tell you it looked like your vault
somewhere like they tie it to the phone
and then your vault is someone I walk in
and it's like that Gary one where
everyone's like Carrie it was gonna
accept our alcohol fig newton and
they're all infected yeah yeah I don't
know I'm gonna keep them
a longer let's see if they see if they
keep updating it was definitely like a
fun little game to play during e3 when
you've got no time when you're managing
your own when you were you know we're
not busy anyway so no not at all and now
there's nothing going on that's true
that's the best part it's the best part
yea year you get to catch up on all your
wits your stuff yeah yeah wait I'm
coming up and I'm off the games come
pretty soon as well and Justin and Andy
thank you so much coming on talk about
fallout 4 duty thanks for having going
to be doing that a lot over the next
coming weeks and months we're going to
Kevin banner on a second to talk about
Batman Arkham niver before that here's a
trailer for FIFA 16 a wonderful Scott
foot suck and Lionel Messi and touching
the ball field again 16 we have used the
latest cutting-edge technology to motion
capture Lionel Messi's movement and
bring his unique abilities to the game
he demonstrated to us how dribbling is
about more than what you do with the
ball sometimes the best touch can be the
one you don't tell Joanna Perlman choc
soon when the opposition kata para
intentar day in December arrow icons
appear Panama oppositely a ser Landor a
new note scribbling system allows you to
emulate Messi's ability to faint and
change direction while dribbling without
touching the ball then once you've
created the space to maneuver you can
exit using a new range of touches as
players react two defenders challenges
completely transforming why
be one situation from the tasman romano
simply my party i'm on to my kisses
better but I only answered one
Machinima's myself pleasure and Ellen
Terry moccasin yes and I live it up
won't you love no touch dribbling is a
tool that all footballers can use and
just like in real life better skill
players will be more effective at using
it as well as being a valuable new way
to beat defenders it allows you to let
the ball roll buying you the time to get
your shot away or pick the killer parts
you'll be able to use it alongside a
whole host of new features to create a
more balanced and exciting game
subscribe for future dev Diaries and
find out more about how we're innovating
all over the pitch 2014 was said to be
the Air Force tumbling pc launches but
it seems like 2015 is following suit as
well Andy Bam and kevin van word where
to talk about batman arkham knight Andy
I want to talk to you about the pc stuff
in a little bit but first of all Kevin
we haven't had a chance to talk since
the review end up throwing up the week
III yea rather busy and we gave a 7 out
of 10 some people were displeased with
that to say the least and was pleased
especially before the game actually came
out yes that's 12 I was uh in the five
days before I actually got a chance to
play it actually put this on my trilogy
of thing of reviews I've gotten the most
hate 40 and so I think I think that oh
god what were the other as he say human
or was one in resin evil 6 was the other
people gave [ __ ] to you from a human a
lot wow I would say that makes up my
trilogy of stuff that for whatever
reason I had the most amount of like
yeah brought directly to me on Twitter
and an email and they're letting so
let's bring it a resonator was up was a
total piece of [ __ ] but what did you put
for it i gota 45 ok fact yeah that sense
yeah I don't think time through working
right on that we had to human had like
problems like for instance the five
minutes it took for the Valkyrie to come
down every time also it's that one was
in number one because the footage which
I didn't take I wasn't playing the in
the footage so some of the footage um
the person who is playing it there was a
bunch there were in the video
there was a bunch of like my armor is
work to human here too bad the other the
other thing is kevin Pereira um did a
video blog um bashing my review all
really that in turn led to one of giant
bombs early videos which was a rap video
that was basically them rapping to uh
kevin Pereira vs kevin van Ord and I
mean I've never even met Kevin prayer
spoke with him but it was it was quite
thing at the time was good times
obviously this one you know I think
maybe the difference is the like seven
out of town gamespot is a pretty great
good yeah I mean I do like you enjoyed
the game I did I did yet so what what
did you like and what what did you have
exception well the things I liked with
the things that sort of carried over
from Arkham City arm moving when you're
not in the Batmobile moving is one of
the best things I in terms of just like
pure joy of movement I don't think any
game really gets it better then uh then
than these games there myself Assassin's
Creed fun yeah I mean as much as I love
assassin creed i would even say you know
i mean at this stage i mean even even
i'm a little tired of Assassin's Creed
but um for Batman I don't think there's
really any game that makes moving
through a city more enjoyable than this
I mean look at that you're bad you're
floating through the city and then when
you get the when you get the hook out
and you're just thrusting yourself
through the city especially that when I
when I leveled up that was one of the
first things I was leveling up to get
that like trilogy like hitting a button
three times and launching yourself
really fast like that's that's the good
stuff and of course the the predator
rooms where you're basically it's it's
you and a bunch of dudes and you get to
use all your gadgets and your fists and
whatever else is like a sort of a vor
training type mini thing is it well what
I what I want I more me yeah I mean I
mean I guess there are some training
some some AR things for predators but I
mean just like whenever the whenever the
mission takes you to a place and you
have to you have to get rid of everybody
regardless of how you do it whether you
beat them up but sometimes you can't
really do that because they've got guns
and even you just got to use your tools
to your best ability that stuff is
really good
and the detecting stuff my favorite
stuff was the detective stuff a few a
few of those were just like wrote like
the murder mysteries more likely you
just do the same thing four times in a
row kind of thing well I'm not played I
am I thought they'd Arkham Knight but
I've played the old ones and a lot of
what you're talking about sounds like
stuff that they have it's like well
trodden Granicus yeah they had really
well in the old games yeah totally uh
and I still think that Arkham Asylum is
one of the best games of of this type
ever made it's not an open-world game
obviously but I still think it's one of
the best you know just action adventures
and what it brought was amazing so uh
and and I I would say though that I
think that arkham city is is pretty much
the superior game to Arkham Knight so
some of it is yeah you know they've trod
this ground before so before we get into
the pc stuff what was what were the
things you sort took exception it I've
been hearing the story isn't is great
the Batmobile stuff can get a bit trite
well one of the that's that's the
biggest for me the biggest thing was uh
the the Batmobile and I and I think that
even now I think that people to play
this game can divide themselves into two
camps liking the you know liking the
Batmobile are not liking the Batmobile
actually driving the Batmobile this
stuff that you're seeing on the screen
now is my favorite stuff with the
Batmobile when you get to speed along
when you get to actually be in the back
wheel and use it as a as a vehicle on
the tank stuff on the other hand can get
it's not so bad on its own but the game
really relies on it so you especially
towards the end of the game you're just
doing all this tank stuff over and over
again it doesn't really involve yours
you're doing the same basic thing from
beginning the game to the end of the
game with that stuff the other stuff too
is the way that it's just shoehorn into
every puzzle and every if you have to
use it yeah there's a lot of stuff where
you have to use the Batmobile and it
leads to some some tedium like one of
the first things you do is you have to
get into a chemical plant you have to
get yeah everybody loves a good crane
puzzle in a video yeah right so you have
to like use the crane to move the ramp
and then you have to go back and use the
crane to move the ramp again then you
have to use the Cray to move the ramp
again and and so it's just like a lot of
that stuff and to me some of the the
puzzle stuff that the Batmobile just got
really tedious especially because you
can see like hey most of the time I
should be able to grapple to that
bit right but now you're taking that
away from me because you have the thing
you want to do with the Batmobile and
that wasn't my proudest moment
regardless of some of the things you
didn't enjoy 70s Thank great review and
you can read it on gamespot com right
now what I want to talk about is
something that happened to fall out
afterwards obviously you reviewed on
PlayStation 4's all right fallout no
site you reviewed so bad I Anton yeah I
totally reviewed Batman on ps4 that was
the only version that we were given yes
so the pc stuff sort of happened after
the fact and so as everyone's probably
more than aware now once the game came
out series of massive problems on the pc
between performance issues and just
crashing and one of the patch has
already come out and just to read some
of the patch notes gives you an idea of
just how bad some of the problems were
so what they fixed was support for frame
rates above 30 frames per second they
put that into the graphics menu fixed
for low resolution texture bugs improve
overall performance add more options to
graphic settings improvements the hard
drive streaming in hitches addresses to
full screen rendering and there was a
problem with nvidia sli there was a
problem with AMD crossfire and and also
they updated the drivers for bowed AMD
and nvidia so this is there's a lot of
stuff there's actually more on this list
and you've been playing on pc and the
you and meri actually were recording at
gamespot plays just over here on friday
and you actually encountered a bunch of
bugs then and there right yeah now you
say they fix problems that have to do
with sli maybe those are made and
problem yeah because we're running a
triple SLI on that machine and there was
points where it just would hard crash
every time it was it was like what were
you like jumping the Batmobile in a
certain mission it's like and just dumps
just crash the data and then once we
turned off some settings and they you
know there's like three or four nvidia
settings if anybody's seen it it's like
more fog and more papers flying on the
streets and it's like it's not hair
works but you know same sort of deal and
we turn those off and we got further in
the game yeah got a little further and
then a car crash again all really i know
and then here we are looking at the
graphics and stuff cuz yeah it's it
looks good on pc but you don't realize
that you're actually missing textures
until you compare its i'm a pirate
suddenly like why should the console
version look better allies are more
detail on the
makes of the Batmobile why on like I've
noticed a lot of panels that Batman like
rips off stuff has no texture his cape
has like weird textures on the pc like
it's all it's all sort of there if you
know what to look for so that's the
weird thing it's like this is almost
like an ignorance is bliss here thing
it's like the Internet age suddenly you
can't get away I'm gonna [ __ ] texture
yeah because you know there are like
high-res graphics comparisons up before
you know what's going on yeah that was a
recording of our progress that's about
what we saw like five or six times but
I've been running on the pc hair work
too with only one grabs card at 97 gtx
970 uh pretty good and I even this is
pre patch I've been running at 60 cuz I
like tweak that I and I file it's like
max frame rate 30 it puts like 11 50 and
and let it go and it's been running
really well but actually like I think
your score kevin is a little generous
like seven really because like what you
said is like the the best parts of the
stuff that carries over from the
original right and there isn't enough
that screens driving me crazy by the way
now that I yeah well now that I know
that that will be look at the missing
textures on the Batmobile it's a weird
anyway anyway the stuff that carries
over there isn't enough there's like
hardly any predator moments yeah they
really do take away a lot of stuff that
I think is the best part of it no yeah
you know it's interesting because then
people say oh then you would have been
you know complaining because it was just
the same thing over and over again maybe
I don't know like I don't know what
hypothetical game that yeah that man
arkham knight without the Batmobile
would have been and it's like the
Batmobile is broken like it don't know
it's like it great yeah it feels fine
it's just like do you really want to sit
there in a batman game moving your tank
every once in a while to dodge telegraph
shots and then shoot like no yeah [ __ ]
no I want to like play against villains
like that's what story about the first
years are so many good villains there's
something good like really big levels
you go through till I get to the villain
like it set up like an episodic thing
almost and it's like awesome and this
one it's like oh go find the penguin and
it's like one little building and then
you go punch the penguin anyway
no bills and in the Arkham Knights not
even a villain in the Batman universe is
it they made him up for this game I
wonder that did they and well that's a
that's another idea what I like too big
it's like well it's not stupid but
whatever it's like frustrating cuz I
want to play batman game where im doing
something with a Batman villain mmm and
Arkham Knight is also the owners are
just talking to you yeah did you go to
you and urging anyone Joker's like your
party imagination all shy of spoilers
all right now which relations without
giving a spoiler warning maybe I decide
I I do think this I think this I do
think that the story is a little bit of
a problem in this game um because the
the things that the things that you're
most supposed to care about 1 of 1 which
is supposedly that is the Arkham Knights
identity the game for shadows it so
strongly for so long that by the time
like there's there's no fun to the
moment the mask comes off because you're
like whatever like you already know
what's coming and and that's the same
for most of the story points for me I
mean I've seen a lot of other people you
know complaining about how you know how
it used the killing joke in a very poor
way and then kind of stuff and I don't
really have much of a feeling about that
particular portion but I do have
feelings about other you know other
story stuff here which is to say I just
I was much more involved with I still
love the Arkham Asylum story a whole lot
great a great series the Rockstar have
developed over the past any rocks are
rock steady haha when we let's with
he'll get with help on one of them yeah
but it's a it's all wrapped up now so
it'll be great to see them work on
something else yeah there's nothing like
about the game though yeah totally took
it's beautiful and me as well and uh but
in the end of somebody were to ask me
you know I'd say just you just play
arkham city again if you like that style
or buy on steam and if it doesn't work
thankfully they've put in that new and
refund problem if it doesn't work yeah
once its back on steam as a backup and
steam I don't know I don't know I mean
official announcement yeah I guess we'll
find out pretty soon yeah yeah so that's
it Andy and Kevin thank you so much for
coming out talking Batman one of the
hottest games to come at this summer
time we've also got a little bit of a
giveaway to talk about now we got
tripped be
yukon marble vjooq on do I you tell me
I've never heard of it it's VG Yukon oh
you never know you sounds video game
University do i yeah that's it a show be
called PG com video game university but
everyone there after he like graduate
high school now is you that's good point
is that show still running I don't even
know how regardless gamespot com ford /
there's there it is right there it's
real easy to me to run to read at vgu
hyphen con hyphen giveaway easy peasy
lemon squeezy games part in partnership
with video games United giving away your
gamers unite a new gamers United we're
all United what football team what
soccer football team do you support real
salt lake babe haha you sort of people
say Arsenal a lot yeah I'm a soccer
season port video gamers any games
United all right so check it out you
want to get over to that conference on
in DC a good old lot of fun so Houma
fallout 4 is well home of bethesda
softworks i believe i think same
virginia well they're bethesda maryland
i think no I don't know they actually
are or maybe they started on east coast
yeah I don't know why I thought they
were still in bethesda that's gary Stein
wrong it says this newest employee and
yeah also deep caught no little gay
gamespot com ford / vgu hyphen con
hyphen giveaway or they'll probably
tweeted it just follow the game spawn
twitter account you'll see right there
that's a lot for this week thank you so
much for watching thank you Andy thank
you Kevin yeah pleasure thanks to all
our guests this week at Aksarben
production in the back eructation while
he was out here for a while as well
America's Josh oo dhan ma horak and
everyone else who's helped we're
production will be back next week until
then and go play the waitress tree or
Batman I'll go go play destiny just
stick it in your brains ya next week
getting it ready for destiny Oh
you